وهذه صور مباشره ايضا تادينها من جزيره
هاواي لثوراني بركان كبير هناك هذا البرك
البركان هو حاليا من اكثر البراكين نشاطا
وهو احد البراكين الخمسه التي تتالف منها
جزر هاواي التابعه للولايات المتحده
وسط المحيط الهادئ وبالعاده يسبق الثوران
البركاني هزات من الزلازل التي تتسبب في
حدوث شقوق في الارض مما يسهل تدفق النيران
بشكل كبير الى الخارج وتتناثر بالطبع
الحمم البركانيه
بركان كلويا في هاواي هذه صور له باعتباره
من اكثر البراكين حول العالم الان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات